[Music]
so we're gonna go to la we've had a lot
of l.a calls today with art hey art how
are you
hey there y'all i'm doing good how about
yourself great what's going on
hey so um
to get started you know i'm a full-time
student i'm a full-time worker
i'm about to hit my mid-20s
and the issue but not crazy issues is i
still live with my folks
i decided to move out at 18 but some
reason i wanted to take care we had a
bad relationship so i just wanted to
take care of that before moving on and
things are better now you know thank god
but um
the issue is that you know they receive
government benefits and i'm feeling a
sense of guilt and worry that if i leave
uh you know they might have they're kind
of in their 60s i don't want them
working to an early grave while i'm out
there taking care of myself but i kind
of have to move out in the sense that i
need to start
my financial independent life as well as
still help them to enjoy their uh their
golden age so i'm kind of stuck between
like i want i want to start my life i've
already delayed it just so i can help
them i want to start my life i but i
feel guilty for leaving
and um
i guess right now that's the just the
general gift of it
well this is this is interesting i i
first of all love your heart that you
care about your parents that comes
through even in your question and you
wanted to
repair any parts of the relationship
that needed to be repaired
tell me a little bit about what the
conversations with your parents are like
what is the expectation what are you how
are you taking care of them financially
now what do they expect is there an
expectation that you are going to stay
there for a lot longer what have these
conversations been like up to this point
uh well the conversations have been
almost non-existent you know they don't
really usually end well so i just try to
avoid them but usually i mean i'm
eastern european so i mean i'm sure
a lot of people understand you know uh
yeah the general idea is you stay with
your folks until you're married yeah and
it's a cultural thing but yeah the
cultural thing personally i've i've
always been had an independent street so
i think my folks are kind of they'll
just go along with what i go with but
um so yeah it really just depends on me
like regardless of the culture their
expectations you know i listen like i
always have an ear open to them but
i i'm at the point where you know it's
also my life that i'm responsible for
not them
but it's just me so if i leave out then
they'll accept that if i don't they'll
accept that uh but expectation-wise in
conversations but i say my um
there's always like a nervousness in my
mother's tongue in regards to finances
just the worries and that's all it is
really like the worries the worries the
words of what's gonna happen next where
they're gonna leave what's gonna happen
with them so uh i don't think she does
this intentionally but her worrying kind
of puts like this
uh like uh i wouldn't say guilt but just
i worry too you know yeah like an
unspoken pressure yeah
yeah how are you supporting them what do
you mean by i'm supporting them
financially are you giving them money
every month as rent
yeah i'm depending on helping them with
a bill just personal things like just
honestly just whatever
just trying to take care of them the
best i can
are you paying bills for them
paying most of them i'm paying most of
them i'm paying about 70 of the bills
wow this is so you're not paying rent
but you're basically covering their life
oh no i'm also paying the rent as well
as the other the other our other bills
okay so this is a very different
situation how much are you giving them a
month total would you say
including bills
like
like minimum a grand a month but like i
usually like throw them like a couple
hundreds extra so we could say like
1300 1200 and are they able to work how
old are they
um well
well my mother is uh
i think in her mid 50s
uh so she so
and my uh my father uh got cancer in the
early 2000s
so uh he wasn't he hasn't been able to
work
for a while
he he physically can't work because of
that
yeah so it's just been me and her is he
on any kind of disability does he get
any income
currently yeah he does you know it's not
it's it's it's it's good it's not
it's not crazy amount but like it's good
for what it is
i'm curious how we got to this point
that you're paying all the bills there i
know y'all it sounds like y'all are not
a family that communicates a whole lot
you said the conversations are kind of
non-existent they don't end well so you
avoid them i i've seen those family
dynamics i know what you're talking
about but something happened to the
point where you started paying those
bills how did those conversations go how
did we get to this point where you're
paying 70 of their expenses
well just kind of what i wanted to do i
figured like it's the
least i could do for them you know all
the things i put them through just uh
yeah i just started when i first got my
offer
yeah let me put this why not okay let me
put this scenario in what if they live
another i mean they're they're young
truthfully uh what if they live another
20 years
and they're expecting you to pay 70 of
their bills his mom's 50. they could
live a lot longer than that so i'm just
wondering there that doesn't seem like
there's a way out here i think you guys
need to have a hard conversation about
an exit strategy and you need to say hey
in six months i'm going to move out and
i want to make sure you guys are taken
care of and this is not a battle where i
want to leave you guys in a lurch this
is me saying i need to live my life and
i want to make sure you guys are taken
care of and you help them develop a plan
for what that looks like for them to
cover their own bills and that might
mean mom needs to go back to work it
might mean dad needs to find something
he can do remote on a computer or
whatever his health maybe allows him to
do maybe it means looking to make sure
they have the right insurance in place
to protect them and so i think you can
help set them up without enabling them
and paying bills for the rest of your
life as you try to start your adult life
well and it sounds like that's what you
you want to be independent art and so
what's keeping you there is not a desire
i hear your heart that you want to take
care of them and i love what exactly
what george said where you're going to
have a conversation that's going to be
an exit strategy that's going to be
gradual over time so that you can pursue
your independent financial life and
independent life
and also
help assist them make sure they're okay
and they they are able to be
self-sufficient i want to acknowledge
one thing your mom's 50.
she's young
she's young
she can work she might not want to work
but if they don't have income she needs
to work someone needs to be working
so that they have income to take care of
themselves and it's not all on you i
love your heart
but it's not all on you and that's not
sustainable long term as well that's
just um you know that and so exactly
like george said you start working on an
exit strategy and bring them into the
conversation hard and are awkward
conversations but you need to have them